[Musique]
très beau talent lisandro du chaudron je
vous sens je me tutoyez je te sens hyper
ému quand tu revois les images ça fait
bizarre vraiment assez vrai ils adorent
c'est normal
je les remercie
crs
et j'ai une petite surprise pour toi
tout de suite tu vois on démarre toutes
les missions comme ça j'ai une petite
surprise pour toi parce que y'a
quelqu'un qu'ils aiment ou choix qui
voulait qu'il venait de laisser un petit
message regarde quoi je pleure bah alors
qu'en mpi n'est pas là les souris
dansent
lisandro jeter niches ne lâche pas je te
lâche pas je te surveille mon pote je
sais que ce soir tat pmp avec mon frère
obama et toute l'équipe des guides
remonte à paris prépare toi parce qu'on
va repartir au boulot mon pote l'équipe
je vous embrasse
prenez soin de vous et à très vite
ciao frérot baba - sam sam houston bon
mâconnais fort qui réussit tout lui
aussi un effet de vol s'ils gagnent avec
lisandro c'est une belle rencontre matt
pokora franchement j'ai vraiment un
coach en or c'est un amour de bec en
fait je pense qu'il a vécu ce que
chanteront de vivre à son âge donc ici
il sait vraiment où me transmettre quoi
en fait donc c'est un coach que que
quitter est clairement de dans mon coeur
pas vraiment